snowing snow everywhere it was there
just like sitting on thinking
what are you doing check this out guys
let's see what they were doing there
what were they doing in the forest look
at this this guy's interesting
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below
you can also use the discount code salam
10
for 10 of their products assalamu
alaikum welcome to a better career
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah
before i start the video brother and
sister there is a young boy who's on the
verge of death they need two million
pounds and they've nearly reached their
target they've been doing this for
months
to save this little young boy he's just
i think one years old just over one
years old
and he needs this specific medication
his muscles aren't working he cannot
breathe for himself
please guys the link's going to be here
i vouch for him a lot turkish
celebrities were involved as well as the
turkish young boy
um and roman sisters please read it for
yourself and you can see
that he needs help please and i'm going
to do another separate video going in
detail about its condition inshallah
let's get straight to the video
inshallah brother and sisters
i was scrolling on um instagram as usual
and i came across one of khabib's boys i
think his cause i'm not sure if his
cousin is one of his boys yes close boys
um and he was he was the one who punched
him i grew up in the face here i think
that's the one i'm not sure anyways so
and i saw him sitting down on a log
in a forest freezing cold snowing snow
everywhere
and he had his like you know his feet
was open and he was there just like
sitting i'm thinking
what's he doing let's go and look for
ourselves what this
brother was doing that really blew me
away and
when i saw it i was like first i didn't
clock where it was
but when i clocked i was like man man it
was amazing and i'm gonna tell you why
it was amazing
let's watch let's get straight into the
show this is instagram so
obviously at first i didn't think what's
going on was i understand what the
language was going on i thought they
didn't do some kind of a prank on it
yeah also last time they got to do a
challenge like you know your presence on
the blog or something like that i don't
know yet
that wasn't the case like they were
speaking as you can see look let's
hear it for herself
now for non-muslims watching this
they've gone thinking okay what's the
big deal the guy sitting on a log
and he's washing his feet he couldn't
wait to get home
okay but as muslims that is
a practice that we do which is one of
the conditions before fulfilling the
salah
the wudu the guy is doing wudu in
freezing temperatures yeah now you might
think to yourself okay maybe he's
they were going somewhere they're on
their way etc and they have to stop the
praise prayer time and you have to stop
you know it's it's
you know not really that wasn't the case
you know
it wasn't that you know what were they
doing in the forest look at this this
guy's interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
that's not a beautiful forest by the way
but what he's doing is more beautiful
now check this out guys let's see what
they were doing there
[Music]
foreign
they were out with the boys on a
bike ride having fun
hold on a second they're out with their
boys
they're having fun yeah now if we was in
this situation brother and sisters if he
was in that situation
what like think about it where would the
boys are having fun it's amazing etc
the last thing a lot of us would want to
do is what praise allah you know we'll
pray after make a hundred excuses
and in this situation surpass us people
living in the west yeah
or whichever country even in the east
where it may be here
we will make any excuse our brother is
too cold
oh this dangerous a tree might fall on
my head um oh we might slip
oh somebody might come and attack us or
there might be a bear 100 excuses
not to make wudu and pray let alone pray
look imagine imagine you guys know what
i'm talking about yet imagine
you we if we had wudu there's a lot of
brothers and sisters and sisters with
the sisters yeah when they get together
with scissors as well
they have will do and they're like oh
you know should we delay it oh we'll
pray later
you know we can pray when they get home
and they have this excuse of oh we can
pray later i know you can't
yeah yeah to make it up salah is two
conditions you forgot
are you sleeping yeah there's no oh i
was shopping i was busy no no when it
comes to salah even if you can't move
your body you can pray with your eyes
that is the condition of salaam that is
the right of allah
what would we do having wudu we would
make excuses because it's cold where
we're going to pray where's the
direction
this guy had no wudu and they stopped
they were in a bike ride look at they
were chilling with the brothers on a
bike ride
that said stop we're having fun good
no problem who is the one enabling us to
have this fun allah who is the one who's
enabled us to give this healthy body to
do this
allah who is the one who feeds us allah
who's the one who gives us
health and everything allah he's the one
who gives a sustenance and risk
yeah and what did they do they said stop
it's time to pray we don't have wudu
we will do wudu in the freezing cold in
the
middle of the forest where some bear
might have come and attacked mans
yeah there might be some crazier crazy
bear crazy bear
yeah there might be a bear all these
dangers listen
and the guy is doing what what's he
doing he's doing wood and look what he
says on his instagram
it happens often we start riding but we
fail to get to the point of destination
but it's not a reason to postpone prayer
because the best act is during the
perfect namaz
those who protect five obligatory namas
by doing their
belts properly by doing their belts
properly okay
and earthly and the earthly obeys earth
obeys
observing observing the time set for
them and knew that this is the truth
truth prescribed by allah he will enter
them to paradise yeah this is the
translation this
let me tell you something allah says
by time everybody is in loss
except except those who believe
yeah those who believe and do righteous
deeds
and call one another to truth and call
one another to patience
this brother by doing this reminder he's
calling people to patience to
truthfulness
to truthfulness what is the truth the
haqq of the namaz yeah
the hack of the namaz that's what he's
calling them to i'm going to end
with this i'm going to end with this
hadith for the prophet peace be upon him
the prophet sallallahu alaihi said when
a muslim or when a mutman or a muslim
servant of allah performs ablution will
do
and he washes his face his sins which
the eye committed by looking are washed
off with the water
or with the last drop of the water when
he washes his hands
the sins which he committed because of
the touch of the hands were washed away
with the water
over the last drop of the water when he
washes his feet the sins which were
committed by walking
of the feet are washed off with the
water over the last drop of the water
until he comes out from the ablution
cleanse from every sin minus him this is
a muslim
brothers and sisters this is amazing
and we're going to end with the verse in
sura in the quran
allah says
pay attention to the last two verses
we're going to recite
[Music]
yes
[Music]
when the earth is shaken in his ultimate
quaking
in his ultimate shaking and when the
earth throws out all its content
all of us that died and everything
some uh fascinating say everything the
goal everything's going to be thrown out
and humanity cries what is wrong with it
on that day the earth will recount
everything
having been inspired by your lord to do
so on that day people will proceed in
separate groups to be shown the
consequences of their deeds
so whoever does an atom way of good will
see it
and whoever does an atom weight of evil
will see it
that little d that you do that little
thing you know just walking this can you
imagine
that little deep that you've done you
disregard it allah wrote it down
that time the second the moment it was
done
allah wrote it don't ever belittle
anything good
anything you you you see an ant you
avoid
uh crushing them that's a good deed and
adam wait
this is our deen and these brothers may
allah bless them
yes the spot that they're in it's all
different story i believe it's not
permissible but
in general the reminder that they give
the importance that they give to salah
and wudu
in that temperature while every single
one of us starts watching this
the rights of allah if you want to do it
if you
understand what allah has given you and
you're grateful to him and you know who
he is
while it can be freezing temperature you
will pray
and if you don't want to pray you'll
find an excuse
brothers and sisters may allah make us
among those who
look and find a reason to pray rather
than excuse not to
five times a day you've got 24 hours
allah only asking five
sisters until next time hope you guys
enjoy this video
please do not forget to help this young
boy to save his life inshallah till next
time
goodbye